optimize what you have going on first to
get that time back to then devote into
something else and I will also say
another thing I love to do when there's
decision moments like this in my life is
I like to go into the DeLorean Travel 88
miles per hour and think about five
years from now what does my perfect day
look like does it involve these two
Brands is it only one of them this way
you can reverse engineer your perfect
day and exactly what your life to be
like because I think too many
entrepreneurs we just say yes the
opportunity because it's an opportunity
that we're worried that is not going to
be around anymore and then I talk to so
many people who are successful on paper
they have multiple businesses and
they're miserable because they're
designing something that isn't actually
fulfilling for them so keep that in mind
think about the future and then reverse
engineer from there